and now this is pretty shocking news uh
let me tell you the very popular podcast
trigonometry which has welcomed guests
from across the political Spectrum but
which dares to platform those who are
sometimes critical of wokism or gender
ideology has had its bank account from
tide Bank canceled the co-founder of
trigonometry is Constantine kissing
who's the author of the best-selling and
immigrants love letter to the west and
he joins me now hi Constantine when do
you find out that your account had been
canceled by this Bank uh we got a
message about a week ago and since that
moment we've been going back and forth
with Tide Bank uh trying to find out
what the reason for them canceling our
bank account was they refused to give us
an explanation which made us very
suspicious we know as you do uh for
example that there are other people in
this country uh fairly mainstream people
actually who've been unable to get a
bank account for their political party
and so on and so because of that we knew
that that is a POS it's a possibility
that this is politically motivated we
still haven't had an answer uh five days
later eventually after many questions
they simply told us they cannot provide
any further information that shut down
the conversation and because of that
today we put a statement out on social
media which went viral we had everyone
from the Free Speech Union to Jordan
Peterson to all sorts of friends and
college uh share this and uh within a
few hours tide suddenly could provide
further information and in fact they
just said that they're investigating
this as a matter of the highest priority
so we'll wait and see to find out uh
what the reason for this is and we'll
take it from that do you have a
suspicion that this is politically
motivated that you've welcomed and your
program is absolutely brilliant and you
listen to speakers from across the
political Spectrum but you've
interviewed the likes of Nigel farage
from GB news could that be your great
crime uh maybe we've also interviewed
Lord Andrew Adonis the arch remainer we
do try to speak to people from all sides
as you say I hope that's not the case I
hope this has been a mistake of some
kind but as I said we do have uh
previous cases and so if that is
obviously something we have thought
about look they they messed with the
wrong people in this instance we already
had several offers from competitor Banks
uh to open an account we've already
taken all our money out of tide and
we'll be finding out what's going on and
frankly you know Mark this wasn't really
ever about us we're always going to be
okay as you said we're pretty big now
and we can wait up the storm what that
concerns me is the contempt with which
they treated us when they told us they
were closing our bank account and if we
were not able to raise these sort of
concerns on social media and get
traction and threaten legal action then
perhaps we we would we would be in a
position where we couldn't get another
bank account and and they would be able
to treat other customers with this sort
of contempt which is one of the reasons
we're watching very carefully what they
say and do and if we're not happy about
it we will join forces with others we
will sue them and we're going to take
this all away because it's completely
unacceptable this disproves the idea
that cancel culture is a myth and it's a
deep DP a chilling development isn't it
we saw us for them which is essentially
a campaign group aimed at protecting the
interests and rights of children they
lost their funding model through PayPal
this free speech Union were canceled by
PayPal you couldn't make it up this is
beyond satire that's why it has to be
opposed right at the beginning I think
and so as I say we will look I don't
have any evidence at the moment that
this is politically motivated I also
don't have any evidence that it's not
because of the complete disregard for
honesty and an open communication that
tired of shown in this instance so we
will wait and see and we will find out
but you're right Mark this has happened
before and so what that means to me is
we really have to make sure that uh we
push back on every instance where
something like this happens we have to
be really Vigilant because what's next
well are we going to cut off electricity
from people that we disagree with if
that is what's happened here uh this is
completely unacceptable in a free
society and so uh yeah it's it's a big
concern you're right and you mentioned
the Free Speech Union the reclaim party
can't get a bank account uh there are
all sorts of these uh situations going
on and uh as I say completely
unacceptable indeed so stay with us for
a moment if you can Constantine because
with us now is Free Speech Champion the
co-founder of the daily skeptic online
newspaper and the founder of the Free
Speech Union Toby Young Toby your
reaction to this story worth stressing
is what Constantine has said there that
we cannot definitively prove prove that
this is somehow a judgment on what
trigonometry do but it's a worrying
development either way yeah it's
extremely concerning
um we're seeing I think increasingly
um channels like trigonometry being
demonetized no platformed by financial
services companies not because they've
done anything lawful unlawful but
because
um the someone some Executives at the
Banking Company the Payment Processing
Company disapprove of the views being
expressed by that organization and you
know they shouldn't have any business uh
censoring the views of people even if
they disapprove of those views they
shouldn't be intervening in debates and
discussions in the Public Square in this
way and trying to promote a particular
ideological agenda whether it's a
left-wing agenda or a roping agenda and
um as Constantine says I mean it
happened to the Free Speech Union it
happened to me personally it happened to
the Daily skeptic last year we kicked up
an enormous fast just as Constantine is
doing now I think it's the right thing
to do
um and in the end all our accounts were
reinstated but it wasn't just us there
were plenty of people who've had their
accounts removed for purely political
reasons not because they've done
anything illegal but just because the
company seemed to disapprove of certain
things they're saying so law or fiction
the UK medical Freedom Alliance
um a company called an organization
called Left lockdown Skeptics was uh
debanked by um PayPal what we're seeing
Mark is the embryonic form of the
Chinese social credit system beginning
to emerge in the west and we have to
draw a line in this in the sand we have
to make it absolutely clear that we
won't tolerate this interference in our
democracy by these companies that often
aren't even based here they're based in
California they're based somewhere
overseas what rate do they have to uh uh
kick people off uh their platforms to
exclude them from the Public Square just
because they happen to disapprove that
they're perfectly lawful views all the
lawful views of people they have on
their shows it's completely unacceptable
we have to draw a line in the sand and
say no we're not going to stand for this
Constantine this is not a confected
culture War this is not a conspiracy
theory is it we saw the Canadian
government freeze the bank accounts of
truckers who objected to vaccine
mandates during the pandemic uh we did
indeed and this is why we're suspicious
as I I gotta keep repeating this because
I I want to be fair but we don't know if
this is politically motivated uh but the
reason we are all concerned is as Toby
mentioned there have been plenty of
cases in this country and in others of
this happening so when it happens to a
podcast look you know our mission of
trigonometry is to have honest
conversations with Fascinating People
about difficult subjects and so I
understand that there is a sensitivity
about the conversations that we have but
I don't think that makes us ineligible
for a bank account I I as Toby says I
don't think people who commit no crime
should ever fear that situation
occurring with them and in our case we
are determined to make sure that this
hasn't happened in this case we're
determined to make sure that tide suffer
the consequences of their behavior even
if this isn't politically motivated I
mean this is not acceptable you can't
shut down people's bank account and
refuse to give them an explanation that
that isn't right and so we're going to
keep pursuing this we're going to wait
and see very carefully what I'd come
back with after their high priority
investigation which they initially
refused to do and if we're not happy
about it all options are on the table
because we're looking out for other
people who may not have the cloud that
we have uh to go after them and make
sure this doesn't happen to anyone else
well on your podcast you interview
figures on the left and the right it's
highly entertaining yourself and Francis
Foster co-created trigonometry it's a
global phenomenon I'd recommend all of
my viewers and listeners give it a try
if they haven't already and support it
in every way they can ditto for the Free
Speech Union and the daily skeptic
online newspaper both
commands just jump in and actually
before you go just to say that actually
the Free Speech Union is so important
because when things like this happen